elon musk has been pitching the idea of
starship
for several years at first starship was
simply an animation that seemed
completely unrealistic
and unreasonable but just last month
spacex successfully flew sn15 to 10
kilometers in altitude
and landed the behemoth using their
wacky belly flop maneuver
there's still a long way to go in terms
of reaching orbit and eventually mars
but as spacex checks off one checkbox
after the other
the prospects of starship are looking
brighter every day
so here's how starship may end up
launching for just 87 dollars per
kilogram
musk initially revealed his ambitious
launch cost for starship in november
when he stated that starship may fly for
just 2 million per mission
and elon's not just talking about
starship or the top half of the rocket
he means that the entire starship system
including both starship
and super heavy will launch for 2
million per mission
with the payload capacity of 100 metric
tons that works out to just
20 dollars per kilogram to put that in
perspective
according to musk it costs spacex 15
million to launch a reused falcon 9.
with the payload capacity of 22.8 metric
tons
this means that the falcon 9 costs about
658 dollars per kilogram
while impressive in its own right that's
not even close to 20
per kilogram so how does spacex plan to
reduce the cost
30 fold well the first major factor
going for starship
is its full reusability falcon 9 is
often praised for its reusable boosters
but falcon 9 itself is actually not
fully reusable
for every falcon 9 launch spacex has to
manufacture new upper stage from scratch
and this is where the majority of the
money goes elon claims that constructing
a new upper stage costs 10 million
dollars
meaning that two-thirds of the cost of
reusing a falcon 9 is simply
constructing
a new upper stage as for the remaining 5
million dollars
a significant portion of this money goes
towards refurbishing the falcon 9
fairings
spacex has been trying to catch the
fairings falling from space using a
couple of ships
but the success rate has been very low
at less than 20 percent
so in april spacex actually gave up on
the effort
and simply settled with fishing the
fairings out of the water the problem
with this plan though
is that saltwater quotes the fairings
which leads to a long and expensive
refurbishment process
manufacturing new fairings cost five to
six million dollars
if we say that refurbishing them only
cost ten percent of that
we get about five hundred thousand
dollars refurbished fairings this leaves
us with four point five million dollars
out of which two hundred fifty thousand
dollars goes towards refurbishing the
booster itself
and two hundred thousand goes towards
fuel this means that about four million
dollars goes towards logistics
operational costs and everything else
involved in launching falcon 9.
given that starship will be fully
reusable we are able to cut out the
expensive costs of manufacturing used
h2s and refurbishing the booster
starship is significantly larger than
falcon 9 though so
we'll say that refurbishing the rocket
cost twice as much at 500 000
what about starships fuel though the
rocket is way bigger than falcon 9
so it'll consume more fuel right well it
would
if it used the same engines as falcon 9
but starship
is actually using much more advanced
raptor engines each raptor engine is
estimated to cost 20
per kilonewton of force per flight for
comparison
each merlin engine which is what is used
in the falcon 9 costs 117 dollars per
kilonewton
per flight so raptor engines are about
six times as cost efficient as merlin
engines
elon musk claims that getting the
starship system to orbit will only cost
900 000
in terms of fuel expenses adding that to
the cost of refurbishing starship
we get one point four million dollars
per launch that still leaves up four
million dollars that spacex spends on
logistics
and operational costs of falcon 9.
unfortunately
these costs won't budge too much from
transitioning to starship
the logistics and operations involved in
launching and refurbishing the starship
will be more efficient than the falcon 9
as spacex won't have to fish out
fairings and move on the components of
starship
as much but starship is much larger
and all those savings will likely just
go into accounting for the size
difference
so we'll say that the miscellaneous cost
of starship remain the same as falcon 9
at about 4 million per launch adding
that to the refurbishment and fuel
expenses
we get a total of 5.4 million dollars
per launch
that's the same as 54 dollars per
kilogram it's not quite the 20
per kilogram that musk was pitching but
it's very possible that spacex does get
there with economies of skill
that's just the marginal cost of
starship though meaning that that's how
much it cost to launch a starship
after it's developed and built
developing and building starships
however
are not cheap by any means so let's take
a look at how much that might cost
starting with research
and development elon musk claims that
developing starship will cost two to
three billion dollars
given the number of unscheduled
disassemblies we've seen so far though
i think we should double that amount to
six billion dollars at today's launch
rate
it would take forever for that
investment to be worth it spacex is
already launching rockets more
frequently than anyone else
but that still only comes out to about
one launch every other week
or about 26 launches per year if we were
to say that the lifespan of the starship
program was 30 years
and that it completed 26 launches per
year we get a total
of 780 launches throughout the program
that works out to 7.7 million
per launch which is obviously very
expensive
but spacex plans to launch starship much
more frequently than just once every
other week
in fact musk wants to launch starship
three times every single day
at that rate starship would complete 32
850 flights over 30 years
in this scenario only 182 650
would be added to the cost of each
flight which is the same as 1.83
per kilogram of payload three flights
per day is extremely ambitious though
i do think that rockets will be launched
at that frequency eventually
but i'm not quite convinced that it'll
happen with starship
if it does it likely won't be till the
end of the starship program
so three flights per day would not be
the average throughout the program
a more realistic outlook would be
starship starting off with the launch
every other week
and then eventually building up to
multiple flights per day after 20 years
this would mean that the average
throughout the program would probably be
closer to one flight per day
at that rate starships would complete 10
950 flights over 30 years
that works out to an r d cost of about
550 thousand dollars per flight or 5.50
per kilogram moving on we have the
construction cost of the starships
themselves
and this is actually a lot lower than
you might expect because of a couple of
factors
first of all spacex dc aluminum and
carbon composites generally used in
rockets
instead spacex chose to use stainless
steel on starships
which is just a fraction of the cost
elon claims that the stainless steel
used on starships only cost three
dollars per kilogram
while the carbon composites used on most
rockets cost 200
per kilogram starship is expected to
have 250 to 300 tons of dry mass
not all of that is stainless steel but
if we assume it is for simplicity
we get about 600 000 worth of stainless
steel per rocket
aside from stainless steel starship is
expected to have six raptors
and super heavy is expected to have 30
raptors so
the starship system will have a total of
36 raptors
each raptor is expected to cost 2
million dollars meaning that the engines
on starship will cost a total
of 72 million dollars if we say that the
cost of labor
logistics testing operations and
everything else cost 28 million
per starship each starship would cost
about 100 million
to construct each raptor is greater for
50 flights
but spacex plans to continue improving
the raptor and eventually get it up to
hundreds of flights
what we'll likely see is starships just
completing a handful of flights before
being retired for the first couple of
years
after the first couple of years of
launches we'll actually see spacex build
up to 10 20 flights per starship before
retirement
between the 10 to 20 year mark we'll
actually see starships complete dozens
of flights before retirement
and it won't be till the 20th 30 year
mark that we see starships complete
hundreds of flights before being retired
so we'll stay conservative and say that
each starship only lasts about 50
flights
on average this works out to 2 million
per launch or 20
per kilogram of payload adding that to
the material cost of each rocket
we get a total of 25.50 per kilogram
and finally that leaves us with
maintenance and repair costs
if we assume that the lifetime cost to
maintain and repair starship is 25
of the cost to build one we get a
maintenance bill of 25 million dollars
spreading that over 50 flights we get
500 dollars per flight
or five dollars per kilogram combine
that with the build cost and we get a
total of thirty dollars and fifty cents
per kilogram
we'll add in another two dollars fifty
cents account for administrative and
miscellaneous expenses
and that brings up our total fixed cost
to 33 dollars per kilogram
if we add that to our marginal cost of
54 per kilogram
we get an overall launch cost of 87 per
kilogram to put that in perspective
nasa's newest rocket space launch system
is expected to cost a total of
2 billion per launch that works out to a
per kilogram cost of twenty eight
thousand
five hundred and seventy one dollars at
that rate starship only cost zero point
three percent
of sls even if starship were to cost 100
times as much at 8 700
per kilogram it would knock sls out of
the park
at the end of the day elon musk has some
pretty ambitious goals with starship
spacex just completed the first fully
successful high altitude flight test
and elon wants to conduct an orbital
test by the end of this year
if starship lives up to his ambitions we
may see starship reaches target of 20
per kilogram near the end of the program
even if it doesn't though
a more realistic average cost throughout
the duration of the program is 87
per kilogram which is still miles ahead
of everyone else
but maybe i'm just being too optimistic
do you guys think that starship will
eventually cost less than 100
per kilogram comment that down below
also
drop a like if you guys can't wait for
the orbital flight test
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one